[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Cloud skills
are in high demand.
A massive 86% of IT leaders say
the skills shortage is slowing
down their cloud projects.
There's now an easy way for
you to hone your cloud skills,
fill this gap, and demonstrate
your cloud competencies.
Introducing Google
Cloud Skill Badges.
You can earn badges for a
range of Google Cloud products
and services like BigQuery,
Kubernetes, Google Assistant,
and more.
Simply complete the
interactive labs,
which cover the latest
in-demand, real-world skills
you need today and take
a final assessment.
Pass that, and the
badge is yours.
Use your badges to gain
recognition in your current job
or to help land a new role.
In fact, a third
of HR professionals
say that digital badges carry
weight in the hiring process.
Ready to go?
Start earning Google
Cloud Skill Badges today.
[MUSIC PLAYING]